[音楽]
[拍手]
私ん
皆さん今熱中していることってありますか
学生の方だと部活動とか勉強
後社会人の方だとお仕事かもしれませんね
恋愛に月柱っていうのもいいと思います
辞書によると熱中とは一つの物事に対して深く心を固め行けるかなことそして夢中に
なることだそうです
熱中は人生を彩り豊かにし
人生の一部もしくは大部分を占めるものです
あなたが熱中することは何ですか
私が熱中することそれはサーフィンです
サーフィンを始めた8歳の私も
今ここに立つ23歳の私も
熱中することの先に道が開けていました
紹介が遅れましたが私は高市みなみと申します
両親がつけてくれたこの名前
實に波と書きます
私たちサーファーは波に乗るために
自分で岸から沖に向かってパドリングして向かいます
そして自分で波を選択し波祈ります
一度来た波は二度と来ません
その乗る事の一瞬一瞬は人生に似ています
そこで今日は私の経験を名前にまつわる
波を用いてお話しします
私はサーフショップを営む両親の影響で8歳の時にサーフィンを始めました
スポーツで経験したのは
水泳とサーフィンくらいで実は運動神経すごくよく見られるんですけど実は海から
上がって陸に上がると運動はあまり得意ではありません
そんな私が唯一熱中したのがサーフィンでした
そして13歳の時初めて日本代表として世界ジュニアサーフィン選手権という国際大会
に出場します
人生における大きなイベントを並みにして表現するとすれば
まさにこれは私が生まれて初めて乗る
ビッグウェーブでした
ホームシックで涙して緊張の中初めての国際大会を経験して
そしてこの波を乗り終えた後
私はまた沖に向かいます
まさにこの経験は私にとって自己最大の波に乗った
そのような気分でした
そしてこの波を乗り終えた後私はまた自分で小出
を機に戻り
和製られない1本の波によります
それは私が日本代表としてエクアドルに向かった時の軽減です
そこでは私よりも年下の子供たちが平日に学校ではなく
ビーツで物売りをして過ごしている様子を目の当たりにしました
学校で普通に学び普通に過ごすこと
それまで当たり前だと思っていたことが当たり前ではない状況に生まれて初めて直面し
ました
この波を乗り終えた後私は自分にできること
について考えます
でも当時高校1年生
考えてもすぐにはわかりませんでした
しかしこの波に乗ったことを経験にして
その後私は自分にできることについて考えながら
また ok 戻ります
おけい戻る最中沖からは大小様々な波が私に向かって押し寄せます
高校3年生になり
日本プロサーフィン連盟公認プロサワーとなり
同年ルーキー刑部ザイヤーを獲得します
そしてここ
徳島大学に入学します
私が
プロサーファーであっプロサーファーとしてプロとして活動することと進学を同時にを
ほなた理由は
海外での経験から
まずは英語と教育に関して学びを深めたいと思ったからです
しかしすべての根底には
時には軽く見られたサーフィンのイメージを払拭し
サーフィンに変化をもたらしたい
と思い私はこの道を選びました
そしてこれが私にできることだと考えたからです
大学入学後あ
英語や教育に関して学びを深めながら
私は世界ツアー主に転戦します
そしてまた海外の家で私は
ます a だいない2本目の波に乗ります
その波は私送る清めました
世界という大きく荒れた並みに挑戦した私は
試合でたくさんの負けを経験します
もちろんま付けた経験は
それからあと成功にもつながりますし
負けたことがあるだけ勝った時の喜びは大きいものでした
しかし世界の壁は厚く負けることで私は自信を失ってきました
それだけでなく
海外で練習中
足を中4針縫うケガをしてしまい
まさにお先真っ暗
出口の見えないトンネルにはまったような気分で過ごしました
いいと思って乗った波から
思い切りこけて
揉まれて苦しみました
しかし私はまだまだサーフィンで挑戦したい
その思いは強く私はまた諦めることなく
沖に向かいます
けがの後はリハビリに専念し
再び波に乗ることができたとき
それまでは当たり前だと思っていたサーフィンの存在が
かけがえのないものであることに気づきました
私てめっちゃサーフィン好きなんやって
思いました
サーフィンができることが当たり前でない幸せであることを再認識して
私はまた勝利に向かって
心を整えて挑戦することができました
この辛く厳しい波を経験した後
私は再び自分にできることについて考えないから
様々なみー法経験をします
大学2年生の時には徳島大学サーフィン部を立ち上げ
徳島の海や自然の魅力を共有することを目的に活動を始めました
また故郷である徳島県阿南市の穴ふるさと大使として活動させていただいたい
また
パタゴニアというアウトドアブランドの
タービンアンバサダーとして
サーフィン
の
プロ活動だけではなく
サーフィンの普及活動や
環境問題にも取り組んできました
そしてサーフィン普及活動の一環として
サーフィンスクールや
小学校での講演なども経験して
自分がプロサーファーとしてできることを一つずつ見つけてきました
そしてまさに今
私は新たな波に乗っているところです
教育活動やサーフィン普及活動を通して教育の重要性を実感した私は
卒業研究として
サーフィンと教育をテーマに研究をします
サーフィンを他のスポーツと同じように学校教育に導入することによって
子どもたちに与える影響を明らかにした方です
アンケート調査によると
この
グラフ
5番になるんですけれども
サーフィンの練習中何度か失敗しても再び挑戦しようと思うという項目に対して
アンケートをつ調査に参加してくれた
サーフィン部に所属する高校生のうちなんと100%がそう思うと回答しました
失敗しても諦めず挑戦する姿勢に私はサーフィンの可能性を感じました
この研究からはサーフィンを教育カリキュラム間に導入することによって
生徒の自己効力感は向上し
そして彼らの健全な発達に影響を与える可能性があることを明らかにしました
そしてサーフィンが持つ教育効果を科学的に証明することができました
そして今度は対象を教育から地域へ移して実行したいと思い
私は今徳島大学大学院で
サーフィンと地域活性化について研究をしています
地ごとの人々
県外から訪れる surfer 移住者の方々
サーフィンができる海岸の近くではさまざまな人がサーフィンとを関わって生活をして
います
サーフィン普及活動だけではなくさあ finger
地域活性化につながることを証明して競技スポーツ生涯スポーツライフスタイなど
さまざまな形で多くの人がサーフィンを通して自然や自然の中でのスポーツを好んで
そして地域が活性化していく
そんな形を作っていきたいと考えています
また
私自身海を愛する者として
サーファーの目を通してみた環境活動にも取り組んでいきたいと考えています
ここには素晴らしい海岸がたくさんあります
これからもサーフィンを通してみた環境問題について考え
地域のあり方についてもう考えていきたいとおもいます
サーフィンができる海岸は世界中にたくさんあります
例えばサーフィン先進国といわれる
大須は嫌やアメリカにもサーファーはたくさん存在していてみんなサーフィンを楽しん
でいます
しかしそれらの国の海岸と日本の海岸とでは大きな違いがあります
それは
サーフィンがその家の文化であるかということです
例えばオーストラリアの海岸では地域ごとに
クラブハウスがあり地元の子どもたちが学校外にそこに集まり
サーフィンを通して交流できます
またニュージーランドではマッチにサーフィンの博物館があり
皆様ご存知の通りアメリカではサーフィンがファッションや音楽など多岐にわたって
文化として根付いています
サーフィンにとって大切なことは
ただ競技人口を増やすことだけではなく
サーフィンができる素晴らしい資源を有する地域において
サーフィンを文化として根付かせることなのです
簡単なことではありませんが私は今自分が出来る事の答えの一つにたどり着いたような
気がしています
皆さん今それぞれに熱中していることがあると思います
一度起きた波は二度と来ない
サーフィンも人生も同じで一度すぎてしまうと二度と戻ってくることはありません
皆さんが今熱中しながら乗っているその1本の波は大切に乗らなければいけません
しかし私も今までそうであったようにこれからも新しい波に乗ってうまく乗れたり
思いっきりコケて失敗することもあるでしょう
確かに同じ波は来ません
しかし
波は実はいくつも起きてるし
失敗しても次の波に乗ればいいのです
チャンスは必ず巡ってきます
ただ挑戦することを恐れず
を機に向かえばまた必ず
波に乗れることを忘れないでください
ありがとうございました
[拍手]
[音楽]
me